good news tom clancy fans the rainbow 6
siege closed beta has been extended
again so there's no need to get Tom and
see before release originally slated to
end on Monday September 28 the rainbow 6
siege beta was first extended to October
the first and now again to October the
fourth players are getting extra time
due to server issues that prevented some
people from playing Ubisoft said in a
blog post in addition Ubisoft is
expanding the number of beta
participants by sending out codes to be
two players to give to their friends
previously the only way to get in was to
pre-order the game yourself not only
will this give you all more time to play
it will give us more time to collect
more data feedback and identify
potential issues the publisher explained
in addition OV soft has announced that
it will hold a double XP event beginning
this Friday October the first of all the
games beta registration page will be
taken down on October the first access
codes from the original pre-order
promotion will be redeemable until
October the second Rainbow six siege was
originally set to launch in October but
was delayed to December Ubisoft has said
siege has the potential to become the
company's best-selling FPS even
surpassing far cry 4 a you signed up to
the betta will you be getting the game
on release let us know in the comments
below I'm Kate you can follow me on
Twitter at how not to draw and make sure
to keep it gamespot for all your news
updates and more news on Rainbow six
siege